Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
El brillante y joven herborista
Xu Xian estaba en problemas.
Podría haber sido
un momento de celebración,
pues acababa de inaugurar
su primera herboristería.
Le había comprado los ingredientes
a un viejo empleador
que, por resentimiento,
le dio hierbas en mal estado.
En tanto intentaba resolver
el destino de tan inútiles materiales,
los pacientes acudían en masa a su tienda.
Una plaga asolaba la ciudad,
y Xu Xian no contaba
con remedios para tratarlos.
Empezaba a desesperarse ante la situación
cuando su esposa, Bai Su Zhen,
elaboró un preparado médico
con las pútridas hierbas del inventario.
El remedio resultante curó de inmediato
a los afectados por la plaga.
Y hasta aquel antiguo jefe se vio obligado
a comprar esas hierbas en mal estado
para curar a su propia familia.
Poco después, un monje llamado
Fa Hai se acercó a Xu Xian
para advertirle que un demonio
habitaba en la casa del joven:
su propia esposa, Bai Su Zhen.
Xu Xian se echó a reír.
Su mujer, ingeniosa y de tan bondadoso
corazón, jamás podría ser un demonio.
Pero Fa Hai insistió.
Le aconsejó darle de tomar
vino de rejalgar
el quinto día del quinto mes,
cuando el poder
de los demonios es más débil.
Le explicó que si no era un demonio,
el vino le sería totalmente inocuo.
Xu Xian despidió al monje con cortesía,
sin la menor intención de dar
a Bai Su Zhen el vino en cuestión.
Pero llegado el día,
decidió dárselo a beber.
En cuanto Bai Su Zhen
tocó el vino con sus labios,
se retiró presurosa a sus aposentos,
alegando un malestar físico.
Xu Xian le preparó un remedio
y acudió a atenderla.
Pero no encontró a su esposa en la cama
sino a una inmensa serpiente blanca
de lengua bífida bañada en sangre.
Tal fue el susto, que el joven
se desplomó y murió en el acto.
Cuando Bai Su Zhen abrió los ojos,
comprendió de inmediato lo sucedido.
En realidad, Bai Su Zhen
era una serpiente inmortal
con poderes mágicos extraordinarios.
Con esos poderes,
había tomado forma humana
para acrecentar su propia
fortuna y la de su marido.
Pero no le servían para
volver a Xu Xian a la vida,
y por ello se le ocurrió
una idea para salvarlo:
conseguir una hierba
que confería longevidad
e incluso resucitaba a los muertos.
La planta estaba custodiada
por el Anciano del Polo Sur
en las cumbres prohibidas
de la cordillera de Kunlun.
La mujer voló hacia
las montañas en una nube.
Luego siguió a pie por arcos y pasarelas
hasta llegar a un puente de plata,
marcado con un cartel que rezaba:
"Paso vedado a los mortales".
Del otro lado del puente,
dos discípulos del Anciano
custodiaban la hierba.
Bai Su Zhen se presentó
disfrazada de monje
y anunció que venía a invitar
al Anciano a una reunión de los dioses.
Cuando se alejaron para llevar el mensaje,
tomó unas hojas de la planta y se marchó.
Los sirvientes advirtieron
el engaño y fueron tras ella.
Bai Su Zhen escupió una esfera
mágica y la lanzó a uno de ellos.
Cuando el otro sirviente ya estaba cerca,
la mujer ocultó la hierba
debajo de su lengua,
pero la magia que surgió de la planta
les devolvió la forma natural.
Mientras la grulla atacaba
a la serpiente con su largo pico,
el Anciano apareció.
Se preguntó: "¿Por qué la serpiente
arriesgaría su vida para robar la hierba,
siendo que ya era inmortal?".
Bai Su Zhen le explicó
su amor por Xu Xian.
Aunque él ya no la quisiera
a su lado por saberla un demonio,
estaba decidida a volverlo a la vida.
Ambos tenían una conexión kármica
que se remontaba a más de mil años.
Cuando Bai Su Zhen
era una pequeña serpiente,
un mendigo estuvo a punto de matarla,
pero un piadoso joven
que por allí pasaba la rescató.
Ese hombre era Xu Xian
en una vida anterior.
Conmovido por la valentía
de la mujer por salvarlo,
el Anciano le permitió marcharse
con la hierba de la inmortalidad.
Bai Su Zhen regresó
para revivir a Xu Xian.
Cuando el joven abrió los ojos,
la mirada que antes expresaba
terror se transformó en sonrisa.
Fuese un demonio o no, era su esposa,
y Xu Xian estaba feliz de volver a verla.